degrom's numbers as gary mentioned and
it's not on this list here
uh the left-handed bets well
left-handers are hitting 152. i guess
that's better than 125 the right-handers
got two fly ball ounce to center now
he's three and two to van meter the
outfield straight away the payoff pitch
check swing did he go around doesn't
matter call strike three got a slider
over the outside corner and that retires
the side van meter with his hands on his
hips doesn't agree starting pitcher for
the diamondbacks is the right hand to
riley smith
six appearances for riley this year half
of those starts he went five innings
tuesday in miami to open up this road
trip called strike three come back two
seamer on the inside corner and riley
smith makes quick work of the mets in
the first we go to the second no score
d-backs of new york 24 left on base in
the first two games escobar though
drives one deep to right conforto back
near the wall leaps and he makes the
catch oh wow
michael conforto playing a gold glow of
caliber right field makes another
tremendous play forto continues to turn
in gems in right field i thought this
ball was going on look at him get back
to the wall
and the way he fell
that is not padded that's a chain-link
fence
that he could he could have got hurt a
little bit there
2-2 coming
and he struck him out 100 miles an hour
right past him second strikeout for
degrom who's now retired the first eight
as a hitter you know how demoralizing
that is gary to get two fastballs and
you're looking fastball
and you take two swings
and that's the result that's uh
demoralizing
o2 coming and he struck him out
the grom over matching rowley smith
perfect through three with three
strikeouts no score at city field
great to see christian and kane looking
healthy and happy and
congratulations to the mccanns for that
great work and james takes one the other
way for the first hit in this game so
mother's day base hit
so now do you have your 462 hitter bunt
i'd give him one strike
[Applause]
the the diamondbacks are not looking for
the bunt from jake
but he does but he might beat this out
escobar bare hands and jake's got a hit
and the ball gets away and mccann will
go to third
how about that
they did not play for the bunt and
degrom made like brett butler and laid
down a beauty for his seventh hit of the
year
is there anything he can't do oh yeah
i mean this is a beautiful bond
i mean they say hitters can't bunt
anymore
you know of course he can get down the
line and he's got those long strides
so now second and third and one out and
the diamondbacks gonna bring the infield
in with francisco lindor coming up
when door hits one out to left center
field that'll get a run in at least and
it is caught by peralta terrific play
tagging and scoring his mccann
with the first run of the game
david peralta gold lover in left field
keep that from being a whole lot more
and now conforto has already saved
degrom with his glove tries to help him
out with his bat two balls and no
strikes the pitch
lope toward left base hit conforto jacob
degrom scores michael conforto didn't do
too much there the pitch was away he
just looped it off the end of his bat
straight into left field he brings home
degrom with a two out run and the mets
have a two nothing lead this is a great
inning for the mets in so many ways
three infielders stacked on the right
for pavon smith vr's backed up near the
shortstop position
on the left side 3-2 pitch
it's in there strike three called on the
outside corner fastball from degrom
pavon smith looked at it and he is the
third straight strikeout victim for
jacob
who has fanned four overall he's retired
ten in a row one out
and van meter fishes for a change up in
that strike three
five strikeouts and four perfect innings
for jacob degrom two-nothing meds
evacs have been going in the other
direction winless on the road trip
they've lost five in a row
and they have pilar hung up trying to
get back to the bag and they got him at
first
laura was just trying to anticipate
first movement from riley smith that
time he guessed wrong broke early for
second base and the bets were able to
pick him off
a long hold and now the 1-2 and stephen
cracks one in the air deep right center
field on the run is pilar over conforto
they both died they can't get it it
bounces up against the fence peralta is
on his way to third he'll hold on there
on a double by stephen vogt and kevin
pilar is down i'll tell you what the
mets just almost had a huge collision as
both guys center fielder and right
fielder
go for that ball at the same time
and they're probably very fortunate they
didn't clip each other so now the
d-backs have the bases loaded with
nobody out madam hangs in the balance
right now
reaches out and pokes the 2-2 up the
middle right to mcneil
peralta comes across and it's a 2-1 ball
game
now there's been five batters in this
inning four have reached base
but degrums got a chance to limit the
damage going to third varnish at first
two down
2-2 to walker
he struck him out
big strikeout for degrom
a roughening for jake but only one run
comes home halfway through two to one
new york well jacob degrom went back to
the mound for the sixth inning through
two warm-up pitches and got the
attention
of the trainer brian chicklow and
they've been conversing ever since luis
rojas has just joined the conversation
of course jake is coming back after a
bout of
lat inflammation
through four perfect innings in this
game he struggled in the fifth and now
after throwing two warm-up pitches he is
leaving this game
and this is of course of great concern
to anybody who follows the mets
trying to escape a mess
2-2 to vote
popped it up
lindor taking charge of it near the
second base bag
side retired
masterful extrication by miguel castro
keeps the mets in the lead
3-1 to mazika
and it's inside ball four and it forces
it a run
another rbi for patrick mazeka
three played appearances in the big
leagues two rbis and the mets now lead
at three to one
and he struck him out
came with heath that time
and escobar goes away and he's been
thrown out of the game yes he has so he
said enough
after the second strike that when he was
muttering as he walked away following
the third strike manny gonzalez had
heard enough and escobar has been
ejected
he got an earful
and now he's throwing out torrey lavello
too
so
having heard enough and with the
diamondbacks fully frustrated
lendore at third confer to its second
with one out
and dom cracks one at a right for a base
head lindora scores conforto will be
held at third
an rbi single for dom smith his first
hit in the series produces a run and
it's four to one new york
[Applause]
here's the payoff
herrera swings and sizzles one to deep
center field pilar going back still
going back he's to the fence he leaps
it's gone
solo home run to center field for us
drupal cabrera and the d-backs have cut
the deficit to 4-2
what a nice at bat by cabrera i mean
that ball was a fastball a little bit up
and when he hit it i knew he hit it well
i didn't know he hit it that well
kind of go opposite gap home run that's
a big one
this will be the 16th pitch
strike three call barnes wins the battle
he picks off the inside corner with a
fastball and on 16 pitches
smith is retired fastball in
three infielders on the right side
against peralta
pulls it on the ground could be two
mcneal has trouble getting out of this
glove out at second out at first double
play side retired
took a little while to develop but the
mets turned two behind diaz to get him
through the top of the eighth four to
two new york
popped it up
who wants it
vr calling and it drops what and the
ball game continues
some miscommunication there between vr
and mccann
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
pour a little mother's day sugar on it
edwin diaz closes it out with his first
mitz five out save